hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar alina vm
spi the extra genital samples
from essay design to real-world
experience
i am michelle ashton of labarus and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics at
abbott we encourage you to participate
today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send all of your questions
will be answered via email
following the webinar today you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers our
first speaker
dr kevin nelson manager assay
development r d
at molecular diagnostics at abbott and
our
second speaker franca azado bacterial
section head
victorian infectious disease reference
laboratory
dougherty institute and at melbourne
australia
welcome you may now begin your
presentations
today i will present on the design and
performance
of the abbott illinois dm sti assay a
multiplex
assay for the simultaneous detection and
differentiation of four common curable
stis chlamydia trachomatis nyseria
gonorrhea
trichomonas vaginalis and mycoplasma
genitalium
these are the disclosures the program is
supported by abbott i am an employee of
abbott
and i'm speaking at their request and
the illinidium
sti assay is ce marked and is not
currently
available in the u.s
for today's talk i will first provide a
brief overview
of the sti disease state i will then
discuss the design of the linda vm
sti assay and finally i'll discuss the
performance of the assay
with oropharyngeal and rectal swab
specimens
new claims that have recently been ce
marked
[Applause]
sexually transmitted infections have
become a growing global health burden
the world health organization estimates
there were 357
million new cases of curable stis in
2012
a number that has not decreased in the
year since that is about one million new
infections
per day four of the most prevalent
curable stis
are caused by infection with chlamydia
trachomatis
nyseria gonorrhea trichomonas vaginalis
and mycoplasma
genitalium the worldwide prevalence of
these infections
range between 0.8 and 5 in women
and 0.6 and 2.7 percent in men
with a high geographic variance in
prevalence rates
chlamydia trachematis or ct
is an obligate intracellular bacteria
and the causative agent of chlamydia the
most common bacterial
sti it infects the urogenital tract in
women and men
as well as non-genital sites such as the
eye throat and rectum
nitria gonorrhea is a bacteria and the
causative
agent of gonorrhea it also infects the
urogenital tract in men and women as
well as non-genital sites such as the
eye
throat and rectum
trichomonas vaginalis or tv is a
protozoan parasite
and the causative agent of
trichomoniasis
it is the most common non-viral sti in
the world
and infects the urogenital tract in
women and men
and finally mycoplasma genitalium or mg
a bacteria that has emerged as an
important causative agent of sexually
transmitted infections
in both men and women it is more common
than
ng but less so than ct it colonizes the
urogenital tract
in men and women as well
i'll go into a bit more detail on each
of these organisms
first ct infects the columnar epithelium
of the cervix and urethra as well as
non-genital sites such as the throat
rectum
and eyes for those many of these
infections are asymptomatic
and may not be diagnosed right away so
the patient has the potential to infect
others
for those who are symptomatic women may
experience
inflammation of the cervix and fallopian
tubes while men experience
inflammation of the testes prostate and
associated structures
untreated urogenital infections in women
can lead to pelvic inflammatory disease
infertility ectopic pregnancy and
chronic pain
transmission from mother to child can
lead to conjunctivitis
nose and throat infections and pneumonia
untreated
individuals are also at a greater risk
of acquiring or transmitting
hiv importantly ct can also infect the
rectum and oropharynx
which can serve as reservoirs for future
infection for those who engage in oral
or
rectal sex rectal infection can lead to
symptomatic pro
bronchitis and pharyngeal infections may
cause a sore throat though it's usually
asymptomatic diagnosis is critical to
ensure appropriate treatment and
enhanced partner notification
nitria gonorrhea is a gram-negative
diplococcus
and can infect the genitals rectum
throat and eye
mysterio gonorrhea can cause acute
inflammation of the cervix and urethra
as well as genital ulceration untreated
infections can also lead to pelvic
inflammatory disease
ectopic pregnancy infertility and
long-term pelvic or
abdominal pain untreated individuals are
also at a greater risk of acquiring or
transmitting
hiv like ct
ng can infect the rectum and oropharynx
and may be symptomatic
or asymptomatic these infections are
most prevalent
in men who have sex with men who engage
in risky sexual behavior
for this reason the cdc recommends
routine ct and ng screening of these
extragenital sites for this population
trichomonas vaginalis is caused by a
protozoan parasite
it's the most prevalent non-viral
sexually transmitted infection
worldwide and 70 to 85 of patients are
asymptomatic
in women the infection can cause
vaginitis
urethritis and cervicitis
tubal infertility pre-term delivery and
low birth weight
infected women are at a higher risk of
acquiring and transmitting
hiv in men the infection can cause
non-gonococcal urethritis
epidemitis or prostatitis
and lastly mycogen microplasma
genitalium
is a bacteria that colonizes the
urogenital tract of both men
and women like the other stis most cases
are asymptomatic
in women mg is detected in 10 to 30
percent
of cervicitis cases and may be
associated
with pelvic inflammatory disease preterm
childbirth
and infertility in men mg is responsible
for
fifteen to twenty percent of non
gonococcal urethritis
and twenty to twenty five percent of
non-chlamydial non-gonococcal urethritis
importantly ng has a high rate of
antimicrobial resistance
making treatment of this infection with
the current sti therapies
less effective
[Applause]
these pathogens have a major impact on
specific populations including those
with existing
stis individuals with multiple sex
partners
msm populations and transgendered people
of note many of these groups overlap
with populations most impacted by
hiv the vulnerable vulnerable
populations to these stis
include young people women mobile
populations
homeless people prisoners drug users and
people affected by conflict and civil
unrest
importantly drug resistance of bacterial
pathogens
may contribute to the spread of
infection to others
the current practice for dealing with
these infections is to treat mostly
based on symptoms
however some treatment regimes
recommended for a specific pathogen
may cause drug resistance to another as
an example
a single dose of azithromycin is more
likely to cause macrolide resistance
in mg than the extended regiment of
azithromycin
so often treatment for urethritis pelvic
inflammatory disease
that is thought to be caused by ct or ng
will cause resistance
if mg is the actual causative agent
ideally before initiating treatment the
clinician would know the exact
pathogen causing the infection so the
treatment is appropriate
this is where the use of a single test
capable of detecting
and discriminating the ideological agent
is beneficial
it allows for appropriate treatment
decreases treatment time and health care
costs
provides timely partner notification
speeds up sti testing in hiv-infected
individuals
and prevents drug resistance importantly
appropriate and timely diagnosis of
these organisms
may lower the spread of stis
particularly in high risk populations
the abbot illinidium sti assay is such a
test that can detect and differentiate
these four pathogens
in one reaction
i will now discuss the design of the
alinity m
sti assay
the elinetti m sti assay is able to
detect
all four organisms ct ng tv and mg
in one single reaction and report the
results
in under 115 minutes the assay has been
designed
to maximize sensitivity and specificity
the molecular targets of ct tv and
mg is ribosomal rna which is present at
many copies per micro
thus increasing the analytical
sensitivity of the assay
this is important particularly for ct
and mg
since they may be present at low
bacterial loads in certain sample types
the molecular target of ng is the
opacity gene
a multi-copy gene with a sequence that
is specific to ng
ensuring no cross reactivity with
closely related neisseria commensal
species
the assay also includes an internal
control and a cellular control
the internal control is an exogenous
armored rna sequence
unrelated to the sda targets and is
included in the amplification reagents
this control is used to confirm that no
pcr inhibitors are present in the sample
the cellular control targets the human
beta globin gene
and serves as a validity check for
sample collection
sample adequacy sample extraction and
amplification efficiency
the alina dm sti assay also includes a
positive and negative control
which are run at a defined frequency
the illinim sti assay has been validated
for use
with endocervical swab specimens
clinician collected vaginal swab
specimens
self-collected vaginal swab specimens in
a clinical setting
female urine and male urine for the
detection of
ct ng tv and mg the assay has also been
validated for use with gynecological
specimens
in preserve site for the detection of
ctng and tv
recently the assay was validated with
additional claims
for use with extragenital specimen types
oropharyngeal and rectal swab specimens
for the detection of ct and ng which i
will discuss
later in the presentation
all urine and swab specimen types
including the extra genital specimen
types are collected with a single
collection kit the alinity m
multi-collect specimen collection kit
the kit is a universal kit that includes
a transfer pipette for adding urine
an individually packaged sterile swab
for swab collection
and a transport tube with stabilizing
buffer and a piercing cap
the piercing cap eliminates the need to
decap specimens prior to running on the
system
the illinois m sti assay is designed for
the alinity m
system a fully automated molecular
analyzer that allows for random and
continuous access for up to 20 onboard
assays
the system can process 300 samples in
about eight hours with a turnaround time
of under 115 minutes
[Applause]
the olympic sti assay data reduction
occurs automatically on the alinity m
system
the pcr signal that is detected for the
target analytes
are processed through a comprehensive
data reduction that involves
signal processing the valuation of pcr
reactivity
and determination of sample validity
this process
ensures reliable result reporting
underpinning the data reduction is max
ratio
an algorithm that transforms pcr curves
into curves with a well-defined
ratio peak this peak reflects the
efficiency of the individual pcr
reaction
and helps determine the validity of the
pcr curve
again this ensures a reliable result
after data processing the elite em
system provides
simple result reporting for each of the
alinity m sti
targets each target in the assay is
individually reported
as positive or negative if a sample is
negative
and fails the internal control or the
cellular control
no result is reported and the sample is
sent to exception
if a sample is positive but has failed
the internal control or cellular control
the result is still reported but gives a
flag informing that the control failed
thus if a sample has a high enough titer
to overcome
low sample input or potential inhibitors
the result can still be reported
this strategy minimizes the number of
required re-tests
[Applause]
with a multiplex assay it may not always
be desired or allowed to report all
pathogens
so the alinity m software allows for
flexible reporting
the system features result locking which
allows customers to lock out any analyte
or combination of analytes from being
ordered or unmasked
for example if only ct and ng are
validated
at a lab they may not want to make tv
and mg available
in this case the lab can lock the assay
to only provide the results for ctn-ng
in the future if the lab validates tv
and or mg
these results can be unlocked and will
become available for order
the alenitdm sti assay also features
unmasking which is the ability to
instantly report out new combinations of
sti organisms
to adjust to the growing needs of the
clinicians and patients
results are reported based on the order
received for the specimen
any organism not requested a time of
ordering can be requested at a later
time to be unmasked within 14 days
of the original order thus if a lab
obtains a request for an add-on test
they no longer need to find the sample
in order to run it again
they can be made available by the
unmasking feature
this slide shows some examples of
locking and unmasking
the top scenario shows what will happen
if ct and ng are unlocked
and tv and mg are locked only ct and ng
are orderable
and only ctn ng can be unmasked
the bottom scenario shows what will
happen if all four analytes are unlocked
all analytes are orderable and can be
unmasked within 14 days
of the original test this feature
enhances flexibility for reporting and
streamlines workflow
saving time and cost to the labs
for the last part of my presentation i
will discuss the key performance
attributes of the elinidim
sci assay with oropharyngeal and rectal
swab specimen types for the detection of
ct
and ng
the limit of detection for extragenital
specimens
was determined by testing dilutions of
cultured ct and ng organisms
in pooled negative oropharyngeal swab
matrix and pooled negative
rectal swab matrix two different strains
were evaluated for each organism in each
matrix
for each strain and matrix a minimum of
three target levels were evaluated with
20 replicates each
the lod was determined to be the
concentration with a detection rate of
95
or greater and as you can see for
ct the lod claim is 0.5 ifu per assay
and for ng is 1.5 cfu per assay
inclusivity of the limiting sti assay
was confirmed by testing 24 replicates
of the following strains
in swab matrix over multiple days at
the claimed lod 16
ct saravars were evaluated and all were
detected at 100 percent
in addition 30 different isolates were
evaluated at 1.5 cfu per assay and again
all strains were detected at 95 percent
or greater
reproducibility of the assay was
evaluated for ct and
ng in swab matrix by testing a
five-member panel
that included a high positive a 3x
claimed lod
one x led and sub lod and negative panel
as you can see reproducibility was
excellent with a hundred percent for
panels at one exclaimed led and higher
in addition the total sd was small the
assay was evaluated for potential
cross-reactants a total of 32
potential cross-reacting microorganisms
that may be found
in the throat or rectum were evaluated
with the alinity m sti assay
no cross reactivity was observed with
bacteria viruses or parasites
that were tested
the potential for interference in the
olyny assay was assessed with 18
substances that may be found in
oropharyngeal or rectal specimen types
again no interference was observed for
any of the substances
to assess the clinical performance of
extra genital specimens
uh a multi-center clinical study was
conducted
in the united states a total of 2
390 symptomatic and asymptomatic
subjects were enrolled
which included 1 256 males
1 108 females and 26 transgender
subjects
three oropharyngeal and three rectal
swab specimens were collected from each
subject
using a common collection device
specimen testing methods included the
alinity m sti assay
and three commercially available ctng
nucleic acid test reference assays
for each orphanageal and rectal specimen
specimens were tested by the elindium
sti assay at two external clinical
testing sites
the reference results were used to
establish an anatomic
site-specific composite reference
standard or crs
using a two of three rule that is if two
comparators were positive the subject
was considered positive for that
anatomic site
and if two comparators were negative
that subject was considered negative for
that anatomic site
the illini m sti assay was compared to
the crs for calculation of sensitivity
and specificity
this slide demonstrates the clinical
performance of ct and ng
by sample type as you can see clinical
sensitivity
was excellent for both targets in both
orphanal
and rectal with sensitivity ranging from
93.3 percent
to 97.2 percent and specificity
greater than 99.3 percent across all
sample types
the overall sensitivity and specificity
for each analyte
across all sample types was 94.3 percent
for ct
uh and 96.2 for ng and the overall
specificity was 99.8 percent for ct and
99.4 percent
for ng
so in conclusion i presented on the
alinity m
sti assay a multiplex assay that can
detect and differentiate
four organisms ct ng tv and mg
in one reaction from multiple sample
types including the most recently added
extragenital samples
we demonstrated excellent ctn ng
clinical sensitivity
and specificity with the extragenital
sample types
the assay includes an internal and
cellular control for process
and sample check for confidence and
negative results
the assay also includes a universal
multi-collect specimen collection kit
for all sample types
which enables easy standardization
across all collection sites
the unlimited m sti assay is an
additional tool
that can be used in clinical management
and public health efforts
and thank you for your time
firstly i would like to thank abbott for
asking me to present on a topic that i
feel very passionately about
and that is spi molecular testing the
title of my presentation
is eliminati m system the future of sti
molecular testing
before i begin i would like to make the
following disclosures
support for the program is provided by
abbott and i
am presenting at the request of abbott
a quick outline of the points that i
will be presenting today
firstly i will give a quick overview of
spis
looking at prevalence and current trends
as well as a brief overview of the
following organisms
chlamydia niceria gonorrhea mycoplasma
genitalium and trichomonas vaginalis
following on from this i will be
presenting data on visuals assessment of
the illinois m
taking a look at operation workflow
assessment and a comparison of the assay
performance to our test of record
i'll finish with some concluding remarks
sti prevalence and current trends
so there are greater than 30 different
bacteria viruses and parasites that are
known to be transmitted through sexual
contact
eight of these pathogens are linked to
the greatest incidence of sti
infections worldwide from the bacterial
group there is chlamydia trachomatis
mysterio gonorrhea
treponema paladin from the parasitic
group trichomonas vaginalis
and from the viral group herpes herpes
simplex virus
human papilloma virus hiv and hepatitis
b
waho estimates that greater than one
million
fpis are acquired every day in 2016
who estimated that 376 million new
infections
caused by one of the following stis
chlamydia
gonorrhea syphilis and trichomonasis
mycoplasma genitalium is emerging as a
cause of persistent non-gonococcal and
non-chlamydia urethritis in men
and may be associated with cervicitis
urethritis
pelvic inflammatory disease and
infertility in women
so this graph shows the increase in
chlamydia and gonorrhea rates across
europe the u.s and australia over a
20-year period
as you can see there's been an increase
in the number of chlamydia
cases over the last 20 years with a
spike seen over the last 10 year period
and with gonorrhea rates it this
have been steady between 96 and 2012 but
there's been an increase in rates in
australia and the us
between 2012 and 2016.
so as an introduction to the four
pathogens that make up the spi
panels let's take a look at the disease
state of each organism
so with chlamydia
the causative pathogen is chlamydia
trichomonas
and it's a gram-negative bacteria it's
the most common bacterial spi
gonorrhea is the second most common
bacterial sti
the causative agent is niceria gonorrhea
and it is also a gram-negative bacteria
trichominosis is the most common
non-viral
sti it is caused by the parasite
trichomonas vaginalis
and mycoplasma genitalium is also a
gram-negative
bacterium and it has been accepted as an
scia
since the early 2000s
site of infection is most similar is
mostly similar across infections
all four organisms infect the
eurogenital tract of both women and men
with ctng also infecting non-genital
sites such as the eye
mouth and rectum symptoms are relatively
similar across all four infections
symptoms in women include acute
inflammation of the cervix vaginal
discharge and dysuria and in men
inflammation of the urethra
and rectum urethral discharge dysuria
urethritis and in some instances
proctitis if these infections are left
untreated consequences include pelvic
inflammatory disease
infertility and preterm birth there is
also evidence of increased risk of
acquiring or transmitting hiv when
infected with these
stis
all four stis have similar presentations
treatment is often syndromic leading to
overuse of antibiotics and the
development of antibiotic resistance
antibiotic resistance is increasing
worldwide in particular for
microplasma genitalium and niceria
gonorrhea making it very difficult to
treat and control
transmission
so with the increasing rates of all four
of these stis both globally and at a
more local level
and with the increasing rates of
antibiotic resistance among nitria
gonorrhea
and mycoplasma genitalium there has
become more emphasis on the
implementation of improved
laboratory testing for these targets in
addition the increase in prevalence has
also increased
the number of test requests that are
being received by laboratories
therefore new molecular based assays
that are designed for high throughput
work
is appealing to many laboratories
as a result
the redraw was the first laboratory in
asia pacific to receive the
linden system for evaluation the
bacteriology department vigil assessed
the technical performance of the
olympian sti assay against the abbott
m2000 which was used routinely to screen
for chlamydia and gonorrhea
and the aniplex sti 7 assay manufactured
by cg
which was used routinely to screen for
mg and trichomonasis
we also assessed the advantages of the
elenidium on laboratory workflow
and operations
so the bacteriology department vigil
services three major spi clinics in
melbourne and
we predict predominantly receive samples
for men who have sex with men
we also receive samples from women from
a women's reproductive and sexual health
clinic
as well as referrals from external
laboratories for confirmation
the majority of samples received are
usually sent for sti screening
as mentioned before many laboratories
have seen a correlation between
increased rates of notification of stis
and an increase in the number of samples
sent for routine screening
for stis in our laboratories we have
laboratory we have also experienced this
trend
data from the department of health and
human services shows the following
that in a five-year period the to the
evaluation of the earlier idiom the
number of
infections recorded for chlamydia and
hysteria gonorrhea
have increased steadily with a 10
overall increase
for chlamydia and a 15
overall increase for nigeria gonorrhoea
a review of the laboratory data shows
that visual ctg requests have also
steadily increased
over the past five years by an average
of 20
yearly so that's shown on in this table
here
and this can be attributed to the
introduction of
prep promotion of prep awareness and spi
testing
and increasing in in the msm population
the table below shows
that the pod shows that positive results
of ctng
account for up to five percent of the
ctng request
it seems that there was a slight spike
in the 2000 in 2017
which could be attributed to the
introduction of prep at one of our
clinics
so looking at the mg pcr and
trichominosis pcr request
received at the draw over a five year
period there has been
a steady increase in mg requests
on on average a 10 increase over the
five years
and for tv requests they have remained
consistent over the five
year period and that's shown in the
orange here
the laboratory data also shows that mg
positives account for
eight percent of the mg requests shown
in this table here
whereas tv positives account for up to
10
of the tv pcr requests
so the laboratory also often receives
ctng
and mgco requested on the same sample
prior to the introduction of the
elimination these samples antoine
underwent multiple extractions and were
processed on two separate platforms
chlamydia and gonorrhea pcr has
routinely been performed on the abbott
m2000 platform whereas
mycoplasma and trichomonas pcr
specimens were extracted on the t-can
automated platform using
a zymo extraction kit
and run on the cfx 96 touch system
using the aniplex 2 sti 7 sa
are manufactured by c gene
data from the five years prior to the
elimination evaluation was reviewed
and the data showed an increase in the
total number of cp and mg code requests
75 of mg requests were co-requested with
cpng
cpng as you can see by this graph
and over the course of the five years
2014 to 2018
the increase in demand for sti testing
impacted our laboratory workflow
so the chlamydia gonorrhea run increased
from one to two runs per day
the sti 7 sa was increased from one run
per week to two runs per week
and daily dna extractions on the tcn
were below 40
samples prior to 2016
and increased to more than 50 per day
due to the surge in the number of
requests both staff workload and
turnaround time have also
increased
so the workflow for comedian gonorrhea
prior to the elimination evaluation
was as follows specimens arrived in the
laboratory and they were processes
sorted according to a worksheet
samples were batched before testing
and this was limited to 96 samples per
run
specimen sorting and batching is tedious
with unnecessary hands-on time
so dna extraction and master mix edition
was performed on the m2000 fp and this
usually takes approximately four hours
um and then amplification and detection
was um done on the abbott m
2000 rt and that takes a further two and
a half
hours data was
manually reviewed and this is an
inefficient use of labor
as well as causing possible
transcription errors and in all the
turnaround time
for 96 samples was seven to eight hours
the workflow for mg and tv
pcr prior to the evaluation of the
elimination was as follows
samples for microplasma and trichomonas
pcr
are received by the laboratory and a
processed and added to a worksheet
dna extraction is performed on the t-can
using a zymer extraction kit and this
usually takes approximately three hours
this is a daily process and samples are
stored at minus 20 until testing is done
um the aniplex sti 7 assay is performed
twice a week
and pcr setup usually takes about 50
minutes
amplification and detection is
performed on the cfx and that
often takes about three and a half hours
and then also data analysis is also
manually reviewed and the turnaround
time for microplasma and trichomonas pcr
request was up to four days
so demand for molecular testing is
expanding rapidly with molecular assays
increasingly
being relied upon for diagnosis
treatment and disease state monitoring
of an array of different diseases with
this
gross also comes in increasing
expectation for accuracy and rapid
turnaround times
laboratories are also constantly under
pressure to consolidate workflow
and to reduce costs and labor the
hands-on time and manual laboratory
processes
including manual testing procedures
molecular training and batch
requirements often create
major staffing difficulties and
this does not just apply to laboratories
in australia but a global challenging
challenge affecting laboratories
worldwide
so the eliminate m was introduced in our
laboratory to address these challenges
the workflow used during our evaluation
was as follows the sample arrives to the
laboratory
and it is processed in a analinity and
multi-collect
tube reagents consumables and waste were
checked
on the instrument instead of sorting and
batching samples like we did with the
previous
testing method samples were directly
loaded onto the instrument
the alina dm reads the specimen barcodes
and downloads test requests
directly from the lif dna extraction
amplification
and detection is all performed on the
one
platform and it takes approximately two
hours and then data analysis
is directly imported
back into our lis negative results are
auto validated
and positive and errors are flagged and
reviewed by the scientists
so the total turnaround time for 96
samples has been reduced
to three hours
so the workflow and operational
comparison between the aberdeen 2000 and
the elenidium showed the following
the turnaround time for first result is
about two and a half hours
about a third of the m2000 hands-on time
per 96 samples was reduced
to 20 minutes freeing up staff to focus
on more value-added roles
research projects and professional
development random access means testing
can before
can be performed at any time rather than
scheduling tests based on batch sizes
provides flexibility in the event of an
urgent sample
unexpected staff shortage or a sudden
change in testing volume
and reagents have a longer onboard
stability and the onboard inventory
management will help
minimize waste
workflow and operational comparison for
mg and tv testing gave similar results
to the
chlamydia gonorrhea workflow comparison
it improved turnaround time
four day days versus two and a half
hours on the elimination
random access capabilities on the
alinity removes batching requirements
for microplasma and trichomonas
and therefore they can be performed
daily instead of twice weekly
a linear dm has eliminated the need for
double handling of specimens
in particular for microplasma genitalium
requests that are
co-requested chlamydia and gonorrhoea
this will
also reduce cost and staff workload as
we no longer need to manually batch and
set up pcr plates
so the data shown here from our
evaluation shows that the illinois dm
has improved our workflow and laboratory
operations
so the elite em stisa evaluation
performed at vigil consisted
consisted of two separate studies
these included a performance of the
alinity mspi assay on neurogenital
samples versus the test of record
and performance of the mstisa on
extragenital sites versus
test of record
the first study looked at the
performance of the elini tm
on eurogenital samples when compared to
test of record
a total of 270 samples were tested these
ranged from vaginal into cervical swabs
and urines
and of these 62 samples were tested for
chlamydia gonorrhea
these consisted of 48 urines 12 vaginal
swabs and two cervical swabs
results were compared to the current
test of record essay which was the
abbott
m2000 real-time cpg assay
and as you can see from this table we
generated the following results so 25
samples were positive for ct
in both assays 37 samples were negative
after ct in both assays six samples
were positive for gonorrhea in both
assays
and 56 samples were negative for
gonorrhea in both
assays so the elimination ct and g
component shows 100
sensitivity and specificity
105 specimens were tested for mycoplasma
genitalium
and 103 samples were tested for
trichomonas
vaginals
and and we're about to evaluate the
stisa performance on these targets
so results obtained showed um that 30
samples were positive for mg
in both assays 73 samples were negative
for mg
in both assays and two samples were
positive in the eliminate
m assay but were negative in the aniplex
2
2 spi 7 discordant results were tested
using the speedx resistance plus mg kit
which is used in the laboratory for mg
resistance testing and both
samples tested positive in that
particular assay so
different gene targets and pcr
technology used to detect mg
in hsa may account for the eliminating m
as they having greater sensitivity
when compared to the antiplex to
sti 7 assay taking a look at the
trichomonas
data 26 samples were positive for
trichomonas
in both assays and seven g7 samples were
negative for trichomonas in both assays
so this study has indicated a
sensitivity
of a hundred percent further detection
of a mycoplasma and trichomonas
and the specific specificity was
calculated at 98
for mg and 100 for tv detection
sti testing performed performed by the
bacteriology department are
predominantly our samples from the msm
community the standard sti screening
protocols for
msm recommends also testing pharyngeal
and rectal sites
therefore there was a need for the
laboratory to validate more specimen
sites for sti testing
a total of 125 extra genital samples
were used in this evaluation of these
93 samples were requested for chlamydia
gonorrhea testing
results show that 25 samples were
positive
for chlamydia and chlamydia in both
assays
67 samples were negative for chlamydia
in both assays
21 samples were positive for gonorrhea
in both assays
and 71 samples were negative for
gonorrhea in both assays
there was a sample that tested negative
for chlamydia in the alinity m
assay but was positive in
the test of record
and there was um equally a sample
that tested negative for a gonorrhea in
the eliminati
m assay but was positive in the test of
record
so further investigation of both
discrepant results indicated that the
results obtained from the abbott
ctg real-time essay we're at the limits
of detection for the test
and it's likely that the target of
interest was diluted out beyond the
limit of detection when the sample was
subsequently tested on the elevation
m so on the basis of this validation we
calculated
a 98 sensitivity and 100
specificity for the chlamydia gonorrhea
assay
of the 125 samples 21 samples were
evaluated for microplasmogenitalium
detection
and 11 samples were evaluated for the
trichomonas detection
evaluation results are presented in the
table
there were nine samples that test the
positive for mycoplasma
genitalium in both assays and there were
10 samples that tested
negative for microplasma in both assays
two samples were positive on the alinity
m
spi assay but tested negative in the
antiplex
2 spi 7 assay um to confirm the
eliminatem
results the two samples were tested
in the speedx resistance plus mg
assay which we currently use in the
laboratory for mg resistance testing
and both of these temp and samples
tested positive in that particular assay
the disgusting as mentioned before could
be due to the different gene targets and
pcr technology used to detect
mg in hsa uh which resulted in the
eliminating
msa having a greater sensitivity when
compared to the
aniplex ii spi 7 assay
the sensitivity was
cap for mg was calculated at 100 percent
and specificity was calculated at 83
percent
um if we take a look at the trichomonas
we can you can see that one sample
tested
positive for trichomonas 10 cent tools
tested negative for trachomonas
in both assays
and um calculus the sensitivity was
calculated at 100
and the specificity was calculated at
100 also
so in conclusion the linearity m spisa
provides
better turnaround time results
than the previous test of record thus
improving the overall management of stis
overall the elinidim stifa demonstrated
good concordance with current test of
record for the detection of
chlamydia gonorrhea microplasma and
trichomonas
across different sample types a linear
dm system is a new and innovative
diagnostic platform that will provide
laboratories with greater flexibility
improved workflow and turnaround times
and staff will be able to work more
more efficiently and perform other
value-added tasks
including research projects to develop
new assays
so in my opinion the addition of the
elimination system will greatly benefit
laboratories
with high throughput it has certainly
made a positive impact on our laboratory
workflow
um so finally i would like to thank um
a few people um from
abbott i'd like to thank adam zambreski
who at the time was the abbott molecular
country manager
nam newan who at the time was the avid
molecular field service engineer
lasalle besser and then at
federal all the victoria bacteriology
staff and in particular eileen hall
who was the main person in the
laboratory doing
this work so i'm happy to take
any questions if anyone has them
thank you again kevin and franca for
your time today
and your informative presentations
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
scientific affairs molecular diagnostics
at abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions all
of your questions will be addressed by
our speakers via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye